it's time for roses and rose eh hello
everyone we are here to talk about my
favorite show The Bachelorette while
drinking some Rose Day this week I got a
mediocre rose a that was on sale and I'm
pairing it perfectly with a mediocre
episode of The Bachelorette let's talk
about what went wrong three words
no Chad president last week we were all
worried how would the show pick up speed
when Chad the train racing ahead into
people's faces disappeared
well it didn't we started the show
revealing that well all's well that does
not end well in Weld ends mm-hmm so
Wells has never kissed Joe Joe it turns
out let that sink in he's a 31 year old
man Wells went in for it but it wasn't
enough Joe just said they were just
friends and she sent him home by E I
will say this for Wells there's kind of
an online campaign popping up for Wells
to be the next Bachelor I don't see it
but I don't hate it
cut to a group date so we're in Buenos
Aires I think oh my god
cheers to me being so offensively bad at
geography Serrano group date in another
country and they play soccer and once
again it's an athletic event and poor
James Taylor and his special songs he
does not know what to do so Jay was
basically just talks about how great all
the other guys look this leads to one of
the absolute worst things you can do as
a bachelor or bachelorette contestant
tattletaling so James Taylor goes to Joe
Joe and he says that Jordan is not the
person that Jojo thinks he is what this
is evidence wait for it wait for it
because this was the pivotal point of
conflicts for the episode Jordan
acted entitled about the rules of Poker
he says that they were playing a game of
poker and that Jordan acted like he knew
the rules of poker and he didn't
necessarily and Pat came off really
entitled we ended on a high note
literally with a montage of Derek
leaving in tears as a singer sang a
rendition don't cry for me Argentina the
hit song written by Andrew Lloyd
Weber about a foot perón some on the
bachelorette give this show an Emmy the
final ending of tonight was a bit of a
letdown
it was teased as Jo Jo does something
that no Bachelorette has ever done
before cheers for trailblazing but what
she did is not doing anything
jo Jo didn't send anyone home in the
very end cheers for trailblazing within
action so to all the entitled
trailblazers out there keep watching The
Bachelorette it's going to keep us
interested and I want to know what you
thought of this week's episode did you
miss Chad did you not did you believe
Derek's tears did you not do you think
these guys are there for the right
reasons I'm exhausted I'm out of rose a
good night